now we come over to this guy now this is
my big object right so which of those
four divisor questions remain a dividend
which of those four is this guy at the
top the theme that is being divided by
this is the dividend try at all they
will that here's my dividend this X
minus five down the bottom this is the
thing doing the dividing so it's the
divisor so what I'm gonna get out of
this is a question and potentially most
likely a remainder whatever that happens
to be I'm going to arrange this just
like I did before all of the machinery
you have in your brain which is good at
numerical division we're going to use it
for polynomial division so I'm gonna
draw exactly the same kind of shape that
I did before like so here's where my
divisor belongs and here is where my
dividend belongs okay now at this point
you're like whoo hold on a second how do
I do what I did over here over there
right it's all perennials and stuff well
don't forget pronumeral like literally
web pronumeral means it stands in front
of our numeral just like a pronoun
stands in front of a noun right so I can
treat these objects just like numbers in
many ways for instance how many times
does X go into x squared how many times
does it go three or four or five times
the answer is I don't know depending on
what X is right if X were say ten how
many time would how many times with ten
go into 100 10 times right what if X was
say 7 that would be 7 this would be 49
so how many times would X go into x
squared that would be 7 times in other
words it keeps changing based on what X
is X goes into x squared x times does
that make sense if you're dividing
they're just normal numbers right you
get this by multiplying these two
together right you get this by any
multiplying these two together okay
now you might say hey why did you just
deal with the X's and just leave off
that negative 5 well I've left it off
for now because I just started with some
nice small
like seven and ten but that X it could
be like a thousand or a million or a
billion this could be the most important
number there okay it's kind of what's
driving everything here so when I'm
performing this first step dividing
right I actually only have to worry
about the X's okay so I'm actually just
going to underline that guy here when
dividing this is the part that matters
okay now your brain might still be a bit
uncomfortable with that because we
didn't do that over here we didn't just
say oh I'm gonna ignore part of the 7
okay but hopefully by the time we get to
the end of this sort of algorithm this
step you'll be convinced that oh does
work this is an okay thing to do okay so
we just did step one we divided we said
X goes into x squared x times what was
the next thing that I did I multiplied
right so I multiplied from here round
down this way okay so I'm going to take
X and multiply it by now I'm not gonna
ignore everything I do need everything
for this next step X minus five what's X
times X minus five x squared right x
times X minus five X and I've written it
down there just like I did before like
with place value but here I don't have
place value I have coefficient value if
you like divide multiply step three was
so check now just just be a teeny bit
careful
unlike in numerical division we have
negative signs that can fly around in
here okay we don't usually have negative
negative signs just hanging out in the
middle of I've got 300 and a negative 10
right because we would cancel them out
but here you can have minus signs so
what happens here just watch out for the
double negative what are you gonna get
these X Squared's they just go for X
take away negative 5 X is 9x are you
okay with that brain still handling all
right I've subtracted subtractions over
what's the last step before I read begin
carry right
go down like so you okay with that now
at this point here we got 235 and then I
just had to go right back to the
beginning and start the dance again does
that make sense so how many times does X
go into 9x remember when dividing this
is the only thing that matters
nine times right if I if X was seven
this would be 63 goes into nine times if
this were nine that would be 90 it goes
in well what did you say ya know if this
would 10 this would be Johnny goes in
nine times you okay with that so where
does the nine go up here multiplied
that's going to be 9 X 9 times negative
5 minus 45 how many so far you okay I'm
up to subtract one takeaway negative 45
46 it's early but not that early I'm at
the end there to carry forward but I
don't have any more things to carry so
what does that mean where am I at this
is finished this is remainder remainder
46
okay now I have an answer now that's
kind of nice I think I think I'm
finished but as you know one of the
things that we always do as
mathematicians is we can check our outs
our thankfully because we can add and
subtract and multiply it's easier to
check whether we were right or not using
this statement that we said before but
with numbers okay if this division
really was right I should be able to
write this and it should all pan out so
this is what I'm suspecting we can do
let's have a look you dividend divisor
quotient remainder okay the dividend was
what did we start with the big guy here
right x squared plus 4 X plus 1
I'm suggesting that going all the way
through this I should be able to say
it's equal to the divisor which pieces
the divisor X minus 5 what a start with
X minus 5 you'll notice I'm not writing
an equal sign just yet because I'm not
sure I want to check right this is the
divisor I'm going to multiply that by
the
yeah the questions over here which
happens to be X plus 9 and then lastly
I've got the remainder hanging at the
end which is 46 this is a going to be a
quadratic right can you please divide or
multiply through rather and check me out
make sure that we actually get the right
answer
have a look are you happy now by the way
you might think hey that's totally
cheating you like knew what the answer
was supposed to be so you just
conveniently put it in there no it's not
true don't forget you're really good at
factorizing objects like this right if I
showed you this guy and I asked you to
factorize you could almost do it in your
sleep I'm out right you look for a pair
of numbers what pair of numbers or what
what do this pair of numbers what do
they do what qualities do they exhibit
which help drive your search the pair
number is going to add to what they're
gonna add to four and they're going to
multiply to negative 45 and that would
take you here right well if you can go
backwards in that way can't you go
forwards in that way as well just add
these two numbers together you get four
just multiply these two numbers you get
negative 45 and tada I'm now happy to
say yeah that's totally equal are you
content does that make sense so your
brain might be slightly in a twist right
now that's okay because for the vast
majority this is completely brand new
you're looking at this and you're like
what does this have to do with this well
hopefully you can see there's a lot to
do with it even though it looks with all
the X's flying around it looks much more
difficult and it will keep feeling that
difficult while it's still sort of early
on and you're just getting used to it's
like dancing with your hands sort of
tied behind your back it's feels weird
to begin with but if actually get used
to it because it's the same moves as it
were okay